did I graduate to adulthood with cooking
[Music]
forget that I can't cut at all
I have attempted to cook a few times but
I can never seem to get it right I also
can't fry things mostly because I'm
afraid of the oil in the pan and if
using like a lid as a shield I have a
number of relatives that have banned me
from the kitchen one of the worst things
I've done is I left a plastic lid on a
casserole and put it in the oven
oh my god oh my god I almost killed my
friends by burning plastic this week I'm
gonna be trying meal subscription boxes
I'm very nervous going into this week
it's hard to say how things will turn
out but I'm hoping for the best you just
throw it all in one bowl so how much
could i really be messin up whoa
okay now two things are happening at
once okay [ __ ] boss so at the
beginning of the week I was I I was
overwhelmed I think to say the least
this is an eggplant right and this is
onion minced garlic I don't even know
what that means and I think anything can
really help me but I'll try I'll keep
trying plan to do it Spann - it was
stressful to me while doing this do this
while doing this mix this together and
also heat this up and that's where my ad
day kicks in damn it
[Music]
well [ __ ] it it all started to move a
lot easier as I went on this looks like
how my mom kitchens looks whenever she's
making something so I'm doing something
right I always feel like if I can do
what my mom is doing then I've become an
adult so I think I've gotten closer to
that label in my soup I feel good about
this smells good it looks like something
I would eat
I think this is the best thing I've ever
made oh my goodness I'm like
legitimately tearing up it is not pink
that's huge I cooked I get it all by
myself and it's great
yeah I'm proud of myself I've never
cooked that many days in a row like
that's definitely a first for me I think
a lot of this had to do with chance but
I'm not gonna like downplay the fact
that I actually cooked a lot of stuff
this is a successful glass dish and I'm
really really happy I did it I made
noodles I conquered the nudes
although the steak made me nervous and
that's why I've been saved it
thought to be the most difficult it
actually was it or maybe I just got good
at it the next time somebody tries to
kick me out of the kitchen I'm gonna be
like no you know what [ __ ] I can be in
here I stepped out of my comfort zone
and now I feel like I can do that again
can't call myself a terrible cook
anymore because I've actually cooked
things there you go
now I can cook I can take a steak I can
do it I can make it medium rare the way
I like it I'm not gonna [ __ ] everything
up
[Music]